[Music]
josh is in atlanta georgia josh welcome
to the ramsey show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
jordan rachel sure how can we help
um so i'm calling in today because i
have um a girlfriend for we've been
dating for a little over a year now um
and i'm actually i guess
i would say a reluctant ramsay height um
and that i've known about
dave and you all for a number of years
at any rate um
recently purchased a home and
basically
want to get out like intense with i'm on
baby step two i only have a thousand
dollars
emergency fund um my question is i
recently signed up in january is coming
up a live financial piece university
that i'll be attending um and i wanted
to see
if um i guess my question is
i'm nervous about i talk to my
girlfriend about it and she wants to do
it with me i'm about 150 000 in debt
um plus my house
she is different um and i guess my
question is kind of where
or i guess when should we you know when
is it appropriate for us to sit down and
talk money and i can kind of hear dave
saying like oh well you need to get
married yesterday
um and then i guess i'm also kind of
nervous like okay well like i need to
save a ring or
try to go into debt for that um are you
guys living together that's what i'm
calling
we are not oh okay
well there's no there's no rush to get
married here and you said she's happy to
join the financial peace university
class
yes okay well then this feels more like
you're scared to tell her how much debt
you're in because of what that might do
to the relationship and how she sees you
yeah right
well i think that's going to come up
naturally in the conversation when you
attend financial peace i think it's a
great place for those conversations to
come up naturally
and uh i think you're you sound like
you're on board to pay this thing off
right now right you're on the plan
you're not ish anymore
i mean
wait can i get home on
are you all in on these baby steps is
when you go through financial peace are
you wanting to get rid of this hundred
fifty thousand as soon as possible
and i i guess that's why i even brought
it up because then let her know that you
know and i think that
yeah because i want to be gazelle like
which is going to cut our lifestyle yeah
totally and i think josh and i think
just being honest with her honestly
on be honest with her honestly but to
sit down and be like
listen this i hate that this number is
following me around that you know the
talk to her about the weight that it
feels
even the embarrassment kind of the shame
and the the regret like let let her in
on all of that i mean that's human
and to say and i'm even embarrassed to
tell you but here's the reality here's
what it is and
uh let's talk through it if you don't
mean like
let it be a very be honest about it and
let it just be a fluid conversation um i
mean if she flips out and she goes well
this this is over then hey there's the
red flag you needed man but if she's all
in on this you're all in on this it's
going to be okay yeah you got this